wofür braucht man guanchale aber geht
nicht wenn dir irgendwas nicht gefällt
daagst das der guanchale kommt wieder
oben auf die Pasta es geht um den Genuss
pastapisia caronara vom Sternekoch
getestet Freunde heute ist ein
besonderer Tag denn Pasta poisia geht in
die zweite Runde wir haben zum
allerersten Mal neue Sorten rausgebracht
und der eine oder andere kennt
vielleicht das Szenario vor dem ich mich
hier befinde wir stehen vor dem
Sternerestaurant von Maximilian Lorenz
und dem werde ich heute meine Pasta
zeigen zeig im sternenkoch meine Pasta
ich weiß nicht was da raus werden soll
gehen wir mal rein begrüßen den Max und
hoffen wir dass er mich nicht komplett
zerrei wie geht's alles gut nudelmaster
ich habe dir was mitgebracht ist ein
ganz natürliches erstes Treffen wir sind
beide schon verkabelt Mensch was Zufall
ich erfriere auch hier in mein T-Shirt
soll wir mal reingen aber ist zu ich
weiß nicht was drin ist ist zu du weißt
nicht was drin ist das wird auf jeden
Fall spannend weil im Kern ist das hier
ein convenience Produkt und mit einem
convenience Produkt in der Sterneküche
zu spazieren ist vielleicht nicht das
allerschlauste aber ihr wisst ich liebe
pastaapisier und wir haben heute
wirklich in unserer Box etwas ich will
nicht sagen revolutionäres aber schon
was revolutionäres und das muss sich
einfach wieder jemandem zeigen weil ich
glaube wir können heute auch bei Max
Lorenz für echte Begeisterung sorgenung
komm legen wir los willst du mal ein
klassisches Unboxing machen wie geht ich
Ken mich dann nicht so aus Messer
aufschneiden aufschneiden das kann ich
das habe ich gelernt ich koche dir jetzt
was wir neues haben ich sag mal so viel
eine Sache wirst du vielleicht gar nicht
so erwartet haben aber wir haben da was
geschafft sage ich einfach mal also wenn
jetzt frikadell sch drin wä das ist
schon eine andere Liga das ist von allen
socen ever mein Favorite die wir bisher
gemacht haben Pomodoro es salsita im
Prinzip Tomate und salsita Wurst die
klassische italienische
fennchelbratwurst die so richtig schön
geil gewürzt ist vertrau mir das wird
Dir schmecken aber guck mal weiter eine
Sache ist wirklich bisschen crazy auch
richtig gottlos ist wenn man die grillt
ja gegrillt ist heiß wow so jetzt bin
ich gespannt jetzt wird's richtig spannt
Parmesankäse weißt du was das ist ich
würde sagen Speck und weil es ein
italienisches Produkt ist würde ich
sagen guanchale der Mann weiß bescheid
wofür braucht man guanchale wir haben
jetzt schon was liegen hol einfach mal
raus weil das ist wirklich geisteskrank
Leute ihr wisstonara aber das geht nicht
denkt man ne geht nicht guck mal was
drin ist du siehst es vielleicht schon
ja es ist auf jeden Fall ist auf jeden
Fall Ei mit drin genau es ist Ei drin es
ist keine Sahne mit drin das hier ist
eine echte italienische Carbonara und
deshalb Leute ich muss da noch mal ein
Video Z machen ich muss euch das zeigen
ich bin wirklich unfassbar stolz wir
haben mit Pasta poesia die
wahrscheinlich erste echte Carbonara
entwickelt die ohne Sahne auskommt und
die jeder sich zu Hause zubereiten kann
viele wissen das gar nicht aber
Carbonara kochst du eigentlich nicht mit
Sahne sondern einfach nur mit Eiern
Nudelwasser wchale es gehört auf jeden
Fall kein pressschinken rein keine Sahne
und bitte nicht die deutsche Variante
keine tkapsen es gibt ja auch andere
köcheer die beanspruchen den Titel aber
Max Lorenz ich durfte mich auch schon
selbst überzeugen ist ja der
selbsternannte beste Koch Italiens
außerhalb Italien da gibt's jetzt noch
jemand anderes aus Hamburg der
wahrscheinlich diesen Titel für sich
behalten will aber ich muss halt einfach
sagen bei der italienischen kücheung
gerade was pas angeht das ist ganz ganz
viel Herz relativ wenig Technik viel
Produkt viel Produkt wenn jetzt mal so
mit der französischen Küche vergleicht
oder der asiatischen ist halt super viel
Technik und hier kochst du einfach so
aus dem aus dem Bauch so B non mit ganz
viel amor das ist schön das sind noch
die begleitenden Nudeln also wir haben
einmal für die Pomodoro ist Hal haben
wir die packeri für die Carbonara wir
dürft es anders sein haben wir Spaghetti
ala kitara also quasi die traditionellen
Spaghetti die quadratisch sind nicht
rund also sehr ursprünglich natürlich
guanchale dabei und das kennst du
allerdings schon metzemanike zum Pesto
Genovese wir konzentrieren uns wirklich
auf die beiden hier und noch mal in
aller Förmlichkeit und auch für die
Kamera sag mir bitte was dir nicht
gefällt du musst mir keinen Gefallen tun
du hast mich hier schon empfangen das
ist schon genug wenn dir irgendwas nicht
gefällt sagst das okay also ich will
eine echte ehrliche meinieren
könen ja die Sachen sind vakuumiert ich
hoffe dass relativ wenig
Konservierungsstoffe drinne sind es sind
gar kein Konservierungsstoffe hast du
gar nicht drin Konservierungsstoffe
Farbstoffe hast du nicht Plastik
Recycling fähig und wir arbeiten daran
nach Möglichkeit zu reduzieren wir
starten Carbonara oder pomodorio salsica
was sagst du Carbonara Carbonara direkt
Carbonara komm los geht's dann beginnen
wir einmal indem wir unsere guanchale
auslassen also Pfanne auf dem Herd also
ganz simpel guanchale in der Pfanne und
auslassen so dass die schön schmilzt ein
bisschen Knusper bekommt und dass wir
dann vor allem ganz wichtig auch ein
bisschen Fett übrig haben in der Pfanne
man sieht jetzt schon schön hier
schwimmt einiges an Fett sind wir
trotzdem noch nicht ganz da aber der
Moment für unseres ist gekommen wie
immer frische Pasta und jetzt das
peinlich Timer auf 5 Minuten was sagst
du dazu das musst du das hast du im
Gefühl das musst Du spüren so jetzt
bräuchte ich eine kleine Schüssel soll
ich m einfach wie zu Hause ich ma das
gerne so jetzt wie immer bei Pasta
poesia weil es einfach bei italienischer
Pasta so gehört nehmen wir uns ein wenig
Nudelwasser an die Seite und die Pasta
später zur perfekten Konsistenz zu
bringen so viel Fett rausgekommen aus
unserem gchale und jetzt holen wir alles
bis auf das Fett aus der Pfanne heraus
gewan Schale zur Seite aber jetzt mal
also ich frage jetzt einfach mal als
Leihe nach der der nicht gar nicht mit
Kochen aus ne gar nicht oft kriegst du
ja sage ich mal solche packages wo du
einfach sagst du hast die Pasta du hast
die Soße prügelst die zusammen glaubst
du dass das ein so krasser Unterschied
ist den jetzt frisch auszulassen ja
definitiv also wenn du wenn wir den
guanchale in der Soße gehabt hätten das
ist ja ein Chip das ist ja das ist ja
Crunch das ja das ist ja eine Textur
wenn das Ding in Soße drin ist hätte es
nicht geklappt wir haben natürlich auch
damit experimentiert weil am Ende des
Tages es soll ja auch einfach sein für
die Leute die zu Hause zubereiten aber
für uns war wichtig dass wir einfach den
Spirit vom Rezept nicht verändern und
ich glaube was nachher der schöne
Grundgedanke ist du kochst noch obwohl
du nicht kochst genau du kochst ohne
kochen zu können genau so also Nudeln
rausholen einmal straight raus in die
Pfanne mit unserem grchalefett die Pfann
ist zu dem Zeitpunkt schon runter von
der Hitze wir arbeiten mit echtem Ei und
Ei kann bei Hitze stocken so also auch
wenn man Pasta poesia zubereitet darauf
muss man achten es darf einfach nicht zu
heiß sein aber dann haben wir jetzt
unsere Pfanne der Herd ist aus ne se gut
nehmen wir unsere Crema
Carbonara rie auch vor allem pcurino ja
pecurino klar klare Sache und jetzt
machen wir es uns ganz leicht Crema
Carbonara drauf geben ich finde das ist
so ein bisschen Trust process ne weil
jetzt gerade denkt man sich so was wird
das aber vertrau mal vertrau mal guter
Schluck Nudelwasser dazu und
dann bisschen Aufregung ist dabei sage
ich euch ganz ehrlich also du frag sich
jetzt vielleicht wie schaffen die Jungs
das ohne
Konservierungsstoffe Pasta mit frischem
Ei frisch zu halten sage ich dir
Betriebsgeheimnis aber guck dir mal
bitte an das ist halt eine Carbonara wie
sie sein soll ne eine wunderschöne Creme
he am Ende heiß ist bestimmt Teller
vorgewärmt ne ich mach Spaß ich mach
Spaß kannte fühen der ist wirklich
vorgewärmt ist das so ein Ding sind hier
alle Teller vorgewärmt ja genau wir
külen im schockfostunter was kaltes
draufle so jetzt drehe ich dir das noch
schnell auf auf den Teller oh da G jetzt
schon Abzüge in der bnote oder unsere
Crema Carbonara
pastapoesia.de jetzt erhält guckt euch
das einfach mal an Leute und wenn ihr
das jetzt zu Hause haben wollt dann geht
mal auf pastapoesia.de wir haben jetzt
gerade verfügbar den dritten Drop und
das gute ist wir haben diesmal wirklich
viel produziert s dass jeder von euch
die Chance haben sollte an eine Box zu
kommen kann trotzdem für nichts
garantieren deshalb besser schnell sein
und jetzt Max kommt die Hochzeit der
guanchale kommt wieder oben auf die
Pasta du hast einfach den Crunch du hast
die Textur so soll eine Carbonara aus
sie riecht wie sie riechen muss sie hat
den Glanz sie sie hat hier sieht man
wenn man das mal bisschen von der Pasta
abkratzt hier vorne z.B sehr sehr schön
le so eine Verbindung eingegangen ich
muss sagen ich kann ich kann auf Cam
nicht schön Essen ist kein Problem es
geht Dich besser fühl es geht um den
Genuss FAS poisier Carbonara vom
Sternekoch
getestet das wir das Wirt so gestaged
jetzt gerade was sagst du Wahnsinn
findst du geil ich muss sagen ich habe
meem leben viele Carbonara gegessen da
waren viele gute dabei und die gehört
auf jeden Fall zum Top
Fünf vielleicht hätte die Pasta aber das
ist individuell gemocht vielleicht eine
Minute länger gekomnt oder 30 Sekunden
ach krass siehst du mal und ich habe
schon die fünf ausgereizt das ist halt
das Ding man muss immer man muss
zwischendurch probieren eigentlich man
man sieht das jetzt hier z.B sehr schön
geh auch mal mit dir rein ja ja bitte wo
wo die Soße oder die Cremigkeit drauf
liegt drückt sich hier Null gut runter
wo hier noch nichts drauf ist ich s noch
relativ freistehend also so ein Zeichen
dass dass die Stärke noch nicht zu 100%
sage ich mal ausgekocht ist was du auch
nicht möchtest aber von der das ist ich
find selbst so krass diese nuan ne und
auch diese diese schaumigkeit die die
Crema Carbonara entwickelt ist wirklich
geil gepart mit guchale diese Würzigkeit
es ist wirklich was besonderes und wir
müssen sagen wir stehen hier in Köln ja
in Köln kannst du zum Feinkost da
kriegst du ganz schade wahrscheinlich
wenn er gerade verfügbar ist aber und
das ist ja unsere Mission mit
pastapesier wir wollen die italienischen
pastaklassiker für jeden verfügbar
machen such mal guanchale wenn du in
irgendeinem 2000 einwohnerdorf im Norden
wohnst und wenn man das alles hat muss
man s ja auch erstmal kochen können
deshalb desb ich finde jeder Mensch
sollte einmal echte Spaghetti Carbonara
gegessen haben und so ist es möglich
deshalb bin ich verdammt Stolz darauf am
Ende des Tages ja ich ma gerade Werbung
für meine Brand aber es ist einfach ein
geiles Produkt ich hätte auch wenn es
nicht mein Produkt wäre hätte ich ein
Video darüber gemacht weil ich es so
geil und faszinierend finde es ist es
ist super lecker und V allem du muss
nicht kochen können und jeder der jetzt
quasi das Video gesehen hat kann das so
zu Hause nachkochen und ich weiß auch
Freunde es werden wieder Kommentare zum
Preis kommen aber das Produkt ist so gut
weil es kostet was es kostet man hätte
Abstriche machen können Verpackung
Versand sind teuer gute Produkte sind
teuer sind noch keine riesenfirma
deshalb bin ich dankbar für jeden der
das sieht der das versteht und der uns
jetzt auf unserem Weg begleitet wir
wollen natürlich am Ende des Tages
wollen wir das jeder am Ende irgendwann
mal in den Genuss von dieser Pasta
kommen kann deshalb Kuss geht raus an
alle die supporten und es ist ein
surales Gefühl das wirklich ein
Sternekoch der Sternekoch also ihr alle
kennt Max Lorenz von vom Channel dass du
jetzt sagst dass das geil ist das das
lässt mich wirklich stolz sein also
jetzt muss man auch mal so ehrlich sagen
das kostet ja auch 1,50 € aber und das
ist das große ABER wenn du dir bei
deinem Lieferdienst was bestellst eine
Carbonara ob sie klassisch ist lecker
etc pp unter 11 12 13 € kriegst du es
nicht hin dann kommt sie lauwarm an dann
hast du gesagt du wolltest sie aber so
haben dann hat das verkackt das machst
du selber relativ wenig Skill Level muss
man einfach sagen ein tolles Endprodukt
in einer hervorragenden Qualität und und
wer kennt das nicht keine Ahnung die
Waschmaschine ist gerade kaputt gegangen
scheiße ich muss noch gerade was für die
Uni fertig machen dann steht das Essen
da das dauert von Anfang bis Ende 8
Minuten ist so ist wirklich
zigarettenlänger ja also das ist ja auch
genau das was wir machen wollen es wird
niem so günstig sein wie eine
supermarktsoße Punkt ist einfach so es
tut mir leid ist so aber wenn es so wäre
könnte es nicht das Produkt sein was es
ist also ich glaube man kratzt schon
sehr an diesen 100% klar hätte ich
vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen mehr
Wasser ins Salz getan die Nudel
vielleicht ein bisschen länger
vielleicht eine Mühe mehr guanchale weil
ich einfach auf ver Fett stehe aber
unterm Strich wenn wir sagen und ich
hätte nicht gewusst dass es von Maxi
pasa s ich hät in einem normalen guten
italienischen Restaurant bekommen hätte
ich gesagt vielen Dank das wäre ein
Grund warum ich wiederkommen würde darf
ich dir dar auf die Hand geben ist
wirklich e Leute es ist wirklich es ist
ein geiler Moment nein es ist aber es
ist ehrlich es ist nicht gestellt ich
ich habe ein breites Kreuz ich würde es
ja auch sagen weil ich nicht lecker fand
wir hatten das ja gehabt mit den drei
pastern wo eine dabei war die jetzt
nicht so mein Favorite war aber die
beiden anderen würde ich mir auch für
mich zu Hause wenn es mal schnell gehen
muss wieder kaufen genau deshalb voll
Transparenz Max meinte die trüffelpaste
aus dem letzten Drop war nicht so sein
Fall das war auch die kontroverseste dir
war zu trüffelig anderen ist es nicht
trüffelig genug man kann es nicht jedem
Recht machen aber ich glaube das ist
einfach authentisch und man kann es
nicht machen aber man kann es
authentisch machen und das sind echte
Spaghetti Carbonara gib ihm und jetzt du
weißt es selbst ne ich habe es dir
gesagt du hast gerade gegessen aber das
hier ist mein Favorite ever okay bin ich
gespannt packerie Pomodoro ist okay so
dann wollen wir mal geht auch wirklich
schnell ich ich raube dir nicht weitere
Zeit ist auch wirklich noch mal
dankechön dass Du uns hier im Betrieb
quasi empfängst der Tacho drückt nämlich
so langsam kein Thema packerie habe ich
einfach festgestellt ist glaube ich mit
so meine lieblingsnudel einfach eine
geile Nudel hat so ein richtig schönen
Biss wir hauen jetzt mal rein 5 bis 7
minut Minuten und eine Sache möchte ich
noch sagen wenn du Bolognese mochtest
dann wirst du das hier lieben Soße ist
warm geworden packerie sind gekocht ein
Schluck Nudelwasser hinzugefügt so dass
schön flüssig ist und jetzt kommen
einfach die packerier oben drauf ich
weiß frag mich gerade innerlich ob ich
mich trauen soll zu schwenken in der
Küche von Max lorence mach doch
ein packerie rauf auf der Teller es ist
wirklich so ein simples Ding aber es ist
ein Traum IT und wie immer ehrliche
Meinung Nudel ist weltklasse mm
großartig mega Konsistenz geiler bis
super du hast wirklich das Gefühl fast
so du beißt in so in so ein gekochten
Tafelspitz von der so ist das schön das
geht eine Melange ein der Parmesan ist
gerade ganz wichtig für mich ich würde
mir vielleicht eine Sache wünschen noch
mehr Pfännchen noch mehr anies also
vielleicht ob man sagt wenn man dieses
Sugo kocht was sehr lecker ist einfach
noch ein bisschen das mehr ausarbeiten
weil jetzt geht's einfach aufgrund weil
so viel weil so viel Power da drin ist
geht das ein bisschen verloren verstehe
was du meinst das ist so eine so eine
umami du hast nicht so diese nicht diese
krasse Feinheit darin aber für mich ist
das halt wirklich eine Pasta zum
reinlegen aber die mal hier vorne
richtig schönes Stück ich würde wegen
der Pasta wiederkommen und das ist ja
nachher das entscheidende und das das
ist einfach lecker sagen ja könnte aber
jenes dieses welches ja okay für mich
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr penchen
oder an aber das ist lecker mehr als ich
mir hätte wünschen können mach du das
Ding mal fertig für euch zu Hause wie
gesagt pastaapisier.de könnt jetzt
bestellen kommt noch was weiteres dazu
einmal die metzanike ein Mal Pesto
Genovese kennt ihr aus dem letzten Drop
ich persönlich bin immer noch geflasht
dass wir es geschafft haben ein
selbstgemachtes Pesto zu verkaufen also
es ist wie selbstgemacht Max vielen
vielen Dank dass du dabei warst ich sehe
schon die Kommentare ein bisschen kommen
dass die Leute sagen das war irgendwie
abgesprochen oder irgendwas klar wir
kennen uns wir mögen uns aber wir mögen
uns so sehr dass Max mir auch gesagt
hätte wenn es scheiße gewesen wä absolut
und wie ich gesagt habe hier ein
bisschen anig die trüffelpasta war nicht
mein Geschmack ich kann ja auch nachher
nur für mich entscheiden klar habe ich
vielleicht eine gewisse fachliche
Expertise mir arbeitet über die
Jahrzehnte aber das ist einfach lecker
das ist einfach macht das kauft das
setzt euch sonntags hin mit einem
Gläschen Rotwein Tatort gucken genauso
wie ich auch und habt einfach eine gute
Zeit Ksten hen als beruflicher
Restaurantkritiker sagt das ist geil
aber es ist nicht geil verliert der
Kredibilität wenn ich in deiner
sternenküche stehe dir meine Pasta koche
und du sagst schmeckt geil dann sagen
die Leute was was labert der wenn es
nicht stimmt also genau überzeugt euch
selbst von der Qualität ich bin stolz
auf jeden Fall schaut bei pastpoesia.de
vorbei und bei Max Lorenz ganz oben
verlinkt in der Beschreibung ihr wisst
Bescheid bis zum nächsten Mal ciao
ciao